ايضا مشاهدينا لازلنا نستمر في هذه
التغطيه لتطورات الاحداث في موسكو شكرا
لاحمد انا ميسون عزام واحييكم طبعا
التطورات هناك اتهمت موسكو كييف بمحاوله
اغتيال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عبر
هجوم بمسيرات على الكرملين مؤكده انها
سترد على الهجوم بالوقت والمكان المناسبين
وفي اول اجراء احترازي منعت روسيا طيران
المسيرات فوق العاصمه موسكو نائب رئيس
مجلس ادوم الروسي قال ان الوقت قد حان
لاطلاق هجوم صاروخي على مقر اقامه الرئيس
الاوكراني
فيما ردت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه بالنفي مؤكده
ان لا علاقه لها بهذا الهجوم على الكرملين
كيف اكدت ان الهجوم على الكرملين قد يتسبب
في رد فعل روسيم متطرف مستشار وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني يفهين ميكيتينكو قال
للعربيه قال ان وقوف اوكرانيا وراء الهجوم
الذي استهدف الكرملين لم يتاكد رسميا ربط
ذلك بح صول الجيش الاوكراني على مسيرات
طويله المدى تسمح بضرب موسكو وهي خطوه لم
تؤكدها كيف ولم تؤكدها او يؤكدها الحلفاء
ايضا
[موسيقى]
ايه دليل بان مسيرات الاوكرانيه او تم
اطلاقها من اوكرانيا لسه مش مؤكد كما
تعرفون الان سيدي الرئيس في زياره رسميه
فنلندا وما سمعتش اي تاكيدات بان مسيرات
اوكرانيه
وفي اول رد امريكيه على الاتهامات الروسيه
الكلاب بمحاوله اغتيال الرئيس بوتين
واشنطن تقول بانها ستحقق في هذه المعلومات
طبعا بعد هجوم طائره مسيره على مبنى
الكريم الرئيس الاوكراني قال بانه كلما
زاد الضغط على العدو كلما انتهى العدوان
وبشكل اسرع كما صرح زلينسكي بان هذا العام
سيكون عاما حاسما لنصر اوكرانيا على روسيا
مزيد معنا من الدبلوماسي والمستشاره
السابقوف اهلا بك
بقراءتك للمشهد الان اذا كانت كيف كما
تقول لا علاقه لها بهذا الاستهداف من
برايك له علاقه ومصلحه بهذا الاستهداف
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
تحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا بصراحه هنا في
اوكرانيا بصفه عامه موجود عده اصدارات مين
حقق هذا الهجوم مضاد اولا اوكرانيا ولكن
ثانيا واحد
اوكرانيا غير متوارثه
هذا المقاومه محليه تحت الارض تحت اسم فلك
المتطوعين الروس الذي موجودين داخل روسيا
وكمان
اصدار الثالث من الممكن هذا الاستفزاز
روسي في الضوء هجوم مضاد متواقع قوات
مصالحه اوكرانيه الروسيه سوف تحتاج جنبيس
الذريع لاستخدام اسلحه النوويه على
اوكرانيا يعني كثير من الاصدارات بصراحه
بمعنى اخر سيد بلد ماهر تقول سيناريوهات
مختلفه
وذكرتها كلها
سيناريوهات تميل اليها اكثر
انا بصراحه اعتقد يعني حققت هذا هجوم اكيد
روسيا
لاستفزازات بصراحه في ضوء هجوم في هجوم
مضادات قوات مصالحه بالمناسبه الان القوات
مصالحه
منذ عشره دقائق سفر الانذار هنا في كيف من
المنتظر بان روسيا سوف يحققوا الزخ من
الصواريخ على اوكرانيا وصوف سوف تسقطوا
المركز اداري في كيف سيدمر البعض يقول انه
لا يمكن لروسيا ان تقوم بهذه العمليه
لانها بالنهايه تؤثر على صورتها حتى
الرئيس الروسي يتاثر على الاقل على
المستوى الداخلي في هيبته اذا ما تم
استهداف الكرملين مباشره في قلب موسكو
بصراحه اذا هذا ليست استفزازات روسيه وعند
روسيا مشاكل كبيره انظمه الدفاع جوي هناك
في روسيا وممكن هلا صحيح لان نحن نشاهد
بان خلال هذا ايام اوكرانيا قصفت بنجاح
شبه
معسكر وقاعده عسكريه تروسيه كما اوكرانيا
اليوم
استهدفت صفه عامه المخازنات العقود
والاخوه يعني بصفه عمل نحن نشاهد
مشاكل كبيره في ضوء هجوم مصالحه اوكرانيه
ولكن بصراحه في اقرب الوقت نحن سوف نعرف
كل شيء بالتفاصيل من حقك هذا او في
المتطوعين الروس او هذه الاستفزازات
خاصه ان الولايات المتحده دخلت على الخط
لتقول بانها ستحقق ايضا وربما نستمع الى
تصريحات رسميه روسيه فيما يتعلق
بوجهه المسيرات من اين اتت وطبيعتها
ومعلومات اخرى ولكن دعني اعود الى
سيناريوهات المطروحه والتي ملت اكثر الى
ان تكون روسيا قد قامت بهذه العمليه
بنفسها حتى تستطيع ان يكون لديها ذريعه
لاستهدافات واستخدامات اخرى من الاسلحه
تصل الى سلاح النووي هل برايك
روسيا بالفعل تحتاج الى ذريعه للتحرك
سؤال جميل بصفه عامه اكيد تروس لا تحتاج
شيء اداريه لاستخدام اسلحه فطاقه مثل
الصواريخ بعد الماده ولكن انا اعتقد
لاستخدام اسلحه نوويه على اوكرانيا اكيد
روسيا سوف تحتاج الى الضريع ولكن انا
شخصيا
سوف تستخدم ان شاء الله على اوكرانيا كل
هذه
الصواريخ يعني نوويه
على كل حال نحن نشاهد
الان قبل هجوم مضاد ولكن ثانيا
اذا كانت روسيا هي التي تقوم بهذا
للاستفزاز
استفزاز عذرا وانت ذكرت بنفسك قضيه النووي
لم اطرحه من بالي انا ولكن دعني اسال سؤال
يتعلق
برؤيتك لماذا تستبعد ان تكون اوكرانيا هي
من قامت بمثل هذه العمليه ان كانت محاوله
الاغتيال الرئيس او حتى لو كانت رساله على
المست وى السياسي هل لانك تؤمن
بتصريحات قيادتك وبالتالي تؤمن انقاله
انها لا علاقه لهم بهذه العمليه فلن يكون
لهم علاقه او لا لانها ربما ليس لديها
التكنولوجيا المتطوره وطائرات مسيره بعيده
المدى كما يقال لتصل الى قلب العاصمه
انا بصراحه يعني اندروسيا مشاكل كبيره
كبيره مع استخدام انظمه الدفاع الجوي لان
هذه المسيرات يستهدفت قلب روسيا قلب موسكو
يعني
من المستحيل بان قوات مصالحه روسيه عجزه
بحمايه جوها فوق الكريم وبهذا السبب
بصراحه انا اعتقد بان هذا اكيد
روسيه او من الممكن اطلقت هضم السيارات
داخل موسكو
لاستخدام الكريم انه اصدق بصراحه شخصيا
لتصريحات
اوكرانيا غير متوارثه بهذا اعتداء يعني
عندهم لا توجد مثل هذه المصايرات طويله
الامد ولكن سوف نرى في اقرب الوقت من حقك
ربما يقول ان هذه هذا الاستهداف وان كان
الاول في قلب العاصمه ليطال الكرملين الا
انه ليس الاول
الذي يرسل رسائل قويه على المستوى ان كان
العسكري او على المستوى السياسي والذي
تتهم فيه اوكرانيا ولا تعترف بالنهايه رغم
انه روسيا في بعض الحالات ومنها استهداف
الجسر في الجرم وغيرها قالت انه لديها
الدلائل على ذلك
اذا موجود الضلاله ينبغي ان روسيا قدمت
صوته قدموا هذه الدلاله في اقرب وقت ولكن
كما نقول الاندلس مشاكل مع نظام انظمه
دفاع جوي وبالمناسبه كمان يضره الحديث في
اوكرانيا بالمانيا ضروري تدمير في عقرب
الوقت جسر الذي ينربط
مع روسيا
مصالحه اوكرانيه ولكن كما انا قلت قبل نحن
في انتظاره هنا
الضخ من الصواريخ من روسيا على مناطق
سكنيه في اوكرانيا بالمناسبه روسيا الان
هي تقصف بشكل عنيف ومدينه
بكميس البيرات الصواريخ ممكن هذا انتقام
على هذا هجوم اعلى موسكو اذا انت تقول
بانه الرد سيكون محصور بالمناطق التي فيها
بالاصل حرب او انه ربما ستتوسع الرقعه
الوصول الى
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو بغض النظر ان كانت
اوكرانيا وراء ذلك او لا واتهام روسيا
لذلك هل يعني باننا الان نتحدث عن حرب
مفتوحه لا تنحصر في جغرافيتها في اوكرانيا
وانما ربما تتوسع اكثر من ذلك وكيف يمكن
ان يكون المشهد
بصراحه من بدايه حرب انا قلت بان روسيا
فتحت الصندوق البندوره بان حرب هي سوف
تعود داخل روسيا نحن نشاهد هذا
الكلمات لمده تقريبا خمسه عندما اوكرانيا
تستهدف بنيه تحتيه عسكريه داخل روسيا ولكن
مهم جدا كمان تصريحات بعض السياسيين الروس
من الضروري تدمير اوكرانيا في عقرب الوقت
بسبب اغتيال محاوله اغتيال البوتين بسبب
القصف
[موسيقى]
ولكن كما نقول انا لا اعتقد ان اوكرانيا
استهدفت هذه الكريم لانه لا توجد عنده
اوكرانيا مثل هذا ممكن هذا استفزازات
روسيه او
العمل الفلك المتطوعين
شكرا جزيلا لك
قال رئيس مجموعه
بدات الان هجومها المضاد واضاف في بيان له
عبر تطبيق تيليجرام اضاف ان قواته لاحظت
نشاطا غير معهود للقوات الاوكرانيه على
طول الجبهه كما توقع ان تنتقل الاشتباكات
الى مرحله اكثر نشاطا في الايام القليله
القادمه
المزيد معنا من موسكو الينا المستشاره
السياسيه في مركز الدراسات الدوليه اهلا
بك سيده ايلينا بدايه تعليق اولي على ما
حدث وقراءتك للرسائل من وراء هذا الحادث
مرحبا بكم
لا بد الان من ضربات عنيفه جدا من قبل
روسيا على اوكرانيا
وسابقا روسيا كانت توجه مثل هذه الضربات
من اجل تدمير البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
الان اكثريه الساسه الروسي يعتقدون بانه
حان الوقت
لضرب
المراكز مراكز القوه في اوكرانيا مراكز
اتخاذ قرارات عسكريه وسياسيه فنحن اقتربنا
من ساعه سفر نحن امام تصعيد مثل ما قال
الان رئيس البرلمان الروسي روسيا تعلن
قريبا النظام الاوكراني نظاما ارهابيا هذا
يعني انه لا يوجد هناك اي محل لاجراء
المفاوضات اما نحن امام
هي كانها بدات الهجوم المضاده هو يشير
ايضا الى انه روسيا كانت متحضره لهذا
الشيء ومن ناحيه هي ستقوم
بصد هذا الهجوم ومن اتجاه اخرى ممكن حتى
ستقوم بالهجوم من طرفها ايضا طيب دعينا
نتحدث عن رد الفعل الروسي المتوقع بعد
قليل ولكن قبل ذلك هل افهم من كلامك بانك
تؤكدين الروايه الروسيه فيما يتعلق بانه
اكياد هي التي استهدفت رغم انه كيف قالت
بان لا علاقه لها بهذا الاستهداف
طيب انا منذ بضعه ساعات كنت في وسط
المدينه قبل ان هذا الخبر وكنت قريبه من
الساحل الحمراء ما لاحظت ان هناك اجراءات
مشدده في المدينه او هناك قلقه او شيء من
هذا النوع ولكننا لا نستطيع ان نصدق بهذا
الشيء لانه راينا صور وراينا تاكيدات
رسميه من قبل روسيا من غير معقول على
روسيا ان تضرب نفسها
وعلى كل الان يقول سيده الينا من ضمن
السيناريوهات المطروحه بدايه انت فنتي
القضيه قضيه ان تضرب روسيا نفسها ولكن
البعض يقول بان هناك ربما تكون معارضه
داخليه قامت بذلك البعض يقول ان ربما يكون
هناك من هم من الروس ولكن يميلون اكثر
للغرب قاموا بمثل هذه العمليه بغض النظر
عن من اعطاهم الضوء الاخضر ليقوموا فيها
بالمقابل ما الذي تستفيده اوكرانيا بمثل
هذا الاستهداف عسكريا لم يجدي شيئا قضيه
استهداف الرئيس الروسي ايضا
لن يكون موجود في ذلك المكان تحديدا يعني
وكان عمليه فيها رساله سياسيه اكثر منها
عسكريه كيف يمكن ان تستفيد اوكرانيا بهذه
العمليه
استبعد تماما ان تكون هناك اي معارضه
داخليه في روسيا تستطيع ان تقوم بمثل هذه
العمليه
فالساحه الحمراء كانت مغلقه في الايام
الاخيره للمشاه وهذا الشيء استثنائي في
اعياد اول ايام عند العمال وايضا في
اعياد تسعه تيار وهي قريبه ايضا مصر اعلى
النازيه فهذا مستبعد برايي تماما تماما
ولكنني اقول حتى لن يكون هذا مهما بعد بعد
قليل لن يكن مهما ما هي طبيعه هذه الضربات
باستخدام مسيرات في قلب روسيا في ساحل
الحمراء في كرملين هذا لن يكون مهما لانه
روسيا ستوجه قريبا
ضربات مجعه بمعنى خرقوا الخطوط الحمراء
هذا ما تقولينه على كل ابقي معي سانتقل
الى مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعم من امام
الكرملين في موسكو لتنقل لنا المشهد من
هناك وردود الفعل واخر التصريحات كاتيا
مرحبا ميسون بالفعل نحن الان نقف امام
الكرملين كما ترين خلفي الكريم الان كما
طبعا كنا قد شهدنا ان الامن هنا مشدد بشكل
كبير يمنع دخول الماره الى باتجاه الساحه
الحمراء طبعا ولكن كما لاحظنا ايضا ان لا
يوجد اثار لاي حريق او لاي شيء نتج عن
الهجوم الذي
تم تنفيذه يوم امس باستخدام المسيرات على
الكرملين طبعا كما كان هناك ردود افعال
كبيره بعد هذا الحادث كان هناك حديث لرئيس
مجلس ادومه الذي قال طبعا ان هذا العمل هو
عمل ارهابي وان هذا الهجوم الذي استهدف
لاغتيال الرئيس الروسي هو بمثابه الهجوم
على الاراضي الروسيه وبالتالي هو دعى
الاستخدام اسلحه جديده لاصابه
القاده في اصحاب القرار في اوكرانيا في
كييف كان قد دعى الى استخدام جديده
للتوجيه الى قلب العاصمه الاوكرانيه في
كييف وهذه الدعوات ليست فقط على لساند
رئيس مجلس الدوما وانما ايضا على عده نواب
كانوا قطعوا الى البدء بالتصفيه الرئيس
زينينسكي الذي تهمه بانه ارهابي وانه كان
يستهدف الرئيس الروسي وبالتالي يستهدف
روسيا تتحدث عن انه وصفه النظام بصوره
عامه الاوكراني بالارهاب ولكن كاتي هل لنا
ان نطلب من المصور ان يحرك الكاميرا لناخذ
صوره اشمل حول ما يحدث حول الكرملين ونكمل
الحديث معك في هذا الوقت اريد الحديث على
الفعل لانه في معظمها كانت
نعم
نعم كما ترون الان خلفنا هو الكريم هذا هو
المشهد بشكل موسع
الساحه الحمراء كما ترين ميسون خلفنا هناك
الساحه الحمراء وكتماري كما ترين ايضا
سيارات رجال الامن هي تقف
على حدود الساحه الحمراء لمنع دخول اي شخص
الى هناك
واذا ايضا كما ترين في الصوره هناك صوره
كامله للكرم لا يوجد اي اثار لاي دخان او
اي حريق او اي اثار لوجود عمليه طبعا بعد
سقوط المسيرات ان يكون هناك اثار لها على
سطح البناء كما ترين المشهد من خلفي طيب
تابعنا تصريحات رئيس المواد
وايضا تصريحات زعماء اخرين ونواب اخرين
وكلها تصعيديه كافيه بحسب مفهمنا والكل
يطالب برد قوي واستخدام الاسلحه كما ذكرتي
جديده ولكن بالمقابل هل نتوقع ان يكون
هناك من تصريح رسمي يخرج به الكرملين حول
تفاصيل هذه المسيرات من اين اتت صناعتها
طويله المدى قصيره المدى او اي معلومات
اخرى تعطينا اشارات تاكيديه على انه
بالفعل اوكرانيا هي من كانت تقف وراء هذه
العمليه
بالفعل ميسون كما تحدثت ان النواب مجلس
الدومه قالوا ان هذا الهجوم هو يشكل بدايه
جديده لمرحله جديده في هذه العمليه
العسكريه التي بداتها اوكرانيا وبالتالي
يمكن ان يكون هناك تصعيد كبير وبالاخص ان
هذا الاستهداف هو ليس يعني هو الاول
بالنوعه وهو استهداف خطير وكما قالوا
النواب ان هو طبعا اختراق للحطوط الخطوط
الحمراء التي وضعتها روسيا وطبعا كما توجه
رئيس مجلس الدومه قال ان الغرب هو ايضا
يساهم بهذه العمليه لانه يقوم بارسال هذه
الاسلحه بشكل مستمر لاوكرانيا وبالتالي هي
تقوم باستخدام الاسلحه لاستهداف الاراضي
الروسيه وبالتالي هي فعلا خطوه تصعيديه
جديده طبعا روسيا كانت كما تحدثت وجهت هذه
الاتهام وجهته الى اوكرانيا ولكن حتى الان
لم يكن هناك اي تفصيل من قبل الجانب
الروسي حول ماهيه استخدام او ماهيه هذه
المسيرات اين اين تم صنعها هي كيما غاتي
او هي بيرقدار او هل تم اطلاقها من اراضي
اوكرانيا لمسافات بعيده عن تم اطلاقها من
داخل العاصمه الروسيه اوكرانيا لذلك نحن
نترقب من جانب الروسي ان يكون هناك ايضا
بيان جديد حول طبيعه المسيره التي تم
اسقاطها فوق الكرملين وبالتالي
هذا ما نترقبه في الساعات اللاحقه او غدا
على تصريحات طبعا المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الكريم الذي سيقوم بالتحدث او بالتفصيل
على سيجيب على اسئله الصحافيين حول طبيعه
هذه المسيرات التي سقطت على سطح الكريم
ان نستمع الى طبيعه الرد الروسي القادم ام
انها ستبقى في مجال التصريحات العامه
وعلينا ان نتابع الميدان
ميسون كما كنا كما اعتدنا على الجانب
الروسي من خلال ليست هذه الاول المره
الاولى التي يتم مهاجمه الاراضي فيها
الاراضي الروسيه وكنا قد شاهدنا ايضا
تفجير جسر القلم خلال الاشهر السابقه ولكن
الرد كان دائما هو طبعا تصعيدي عسكري هو
ميداني طبعا كما ذكرتي انت سيكون هناك
بالطبع تصعيد من الجانب الروسي وبالاخص ان
هذا هذا الاستهداف وياتي قبيل عيد النصر
لذلك يتوقع او يترقب الشارع الروسي
والخبراء الروس ان يكون هناك تصعيد كبير
وهجوم موسع على الاراضي الاوكرانيه خلال
الايام السابقه اولا كرد بمثابه رد على
هذا الاستهداف الذي هو كان استهداف لشخص
الرئيس الروسي
بحسب
التصري
باستهداف طبعا باستهداف جميع مستودعات
الاسلحه
طبعا لمقاومه اي من الجانب الاوكراني التي
الذي طبعا يستعد لهجوم مضاد على الاراضي
الروسيه لذلك ستقوم بتكثيف هذه العمليات
عمليات استهداف المستودعات العهد الاتحاد
الاوكرانيه النائب واخر من خلال التصريحات
الروسيه الزعيم رينوف يقول انه علينا
القضاء على النخبه الارهابيه في اوكرانيا
نائب شرمت يقول يجب استهداف مقر اقامه
زيلينسكي اضافه الى نائب اخر يتحدث عن انه
لم تعد هناك اي خطوط حمراء بعد هذا اليوم
ونائب اخر يقول يجب تدمير مكتب الرئيس
تدمير البرلمان الاوكراني هيئه الاركان
العامه والمباني التي تضم الخدمات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه على الارض على كل ابقي كاتيا
نعود اليك بحال ورود اي جديد اسمحي لي ان
اعود الى ضيفه طبعا الينا الينا ذكرنا قبل
قليل موقف الولايات المتحده والتصريح
الاول فيما يتعلق بهذه الحادثه الولايات
المتحده تريد ان تحقق
الحدث ومسؤول امريكي لرويترز يقول لا
يمكننا حتى الان تاكيد روايه روسيا بشان
الهجوم على
واشنطن تقول انها ستحاول التحقق من هذه
الاتهامات بشان محاوله اغتيال بوتين هل
نفهم من هذه التصريحات ان الولايات
المتحده ربما ليس ايضا لديها اي علاقه
بهذه الضربه لان البعض كان يقول انه
اوكرانيا اذا ما كانت هي وراء هذه العمليه
فلا بد من انها اخذت الضوء الاخضر من
الولايات المتحده
نحن لا نصدق امريكان
بالنسبه لاروسيا الان غير مهم هل هم
يؤكدون هذه المعلومات وهذه الصور اما لا
يؤكدون بعد ما غزوه العراق
اعتمادا على دلائل مزيفه حول حول اسلحه
الدمار الشامل ليس لهم حق ان
يصرحوا اي شيء في هذا المجال
روسيا الان اقتربت من صعد صفر انا اعمل ان
تكون روسيا قد حضرت نفسها لهذا الشيء عندك
شك ان تكون قد حضرت نفسها لذلك
والله انا اعتقد انه روسيا حضرت نفسها
لازاله
لنرى ماذا سيحدث اليوم بالليل او الصبح
فجر فانا اتوقع انه ضربات ستكون قريبه
ممكن
سنستيقظ غدا الصباح
باخبار حتى الغد خلينا نركز على التصريحات
الامريكيه بلينتن يقول لا يمكننا التحقق
من صحه تقارير استهداف بوتين في الكرملين
بمثيرات لا اعلم ان كان بالامكانيه قراءه
هذه التصريحات هل هو يشكك بانه العمليه
كانت كعمليه اغتيال او بالعمليه برمتها هل
تستطيعين قراءه تصريحاته او لا
والله انا لا اعرف شو هو في مخها
ولكنهم لا يثقون من زمان ولكن روسيا ايضا
لا تبقى بامريكان اهم شيء وراء هذه
التصريحات انه لن تكون هناك جهود تفاوضيه
قريبا وحتى البساطه الصينيه هي يمكن
اظهرها بانه الطرف الاوكراني غير مستعد
لاجراء المفاوضات
على احصانا ليبرا يهرب لي شيء مكان
يقول نحن ببساطه لا نعرف ما الذي حدث في
الكرملين وبالتالي السؤال هل روسيا معنيه
بتوضيح الامر ان كان للولايات المتحده او
للعالم بصوره عامه في ظل هذا التشكيك
روسيا الان وضحت بكل الوضوح انها من نقطه
اليوم هي اعتبرت النظام في اوكرانيا غير
مستعدا لاجراء مفاوضات قريبا البرلمان
الروسي حيا يعلن بانه النظام في
اوكسيكي نفسه وهم ارهابيين وهذا يعني انه
ستحق روسيا استخدام كل الوسائل للقضاء على
ما تعتبره ارهابيين طيب الينا ابقي معي
ينضم الي الان طبعا محمد البابا
الصحفي من اكياف محمد اهلا بك اي تصريحات
جديده استمعنا الى تصريحات الاخيره التي
تقول ان كيابل لا علاقه لها بما حدث اي
تصريحات جديده وردود الفعل لو سمحت
يعني الموقف الرسمي الوحيد الذي خرج عن
الاداره الرئاسيه قبل دقائق سلكيه المتحدث
باسم الرئاسه الاوكرانيه قال ان لا علاقه
لاوكرانيا بالهجوم الذي تعرض له ليله امس
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
اعرب انه لا علاقه لاوكرانيا بالهجوم الذي
حصل في موسكو او في ليله امس ما يعني ان
الجانب الاوكراني يمشي تماما وعبر المتحدث
باسم الرئاسه الاوكرانيه اي علاقه
لاوكرانيا او للسلطات الاوكرانيه او الجيش
الاوكراني كما يفهم من خلال هذا التصريح
للهجوم الذي حصل في الكريمه من هجوم
اوكرانيا مسؤوليتها عنها هل كان من
المتوقع لو كانت اوكرانيا وراء هذا الهجوم
ان تعترف بذلك بحسب المراقبين طبعا
عاده يعني ما رايناه خلال يعني ثلاثه او
اربعه عشر شهرا من بدء الغاز الروسي
للاراضي الاوكرانيه لن يعني عندما حصل
الهجوم على جسر القرن جسم قرش لم يصدر اي
بيان بالنفي او التاكيد من الجانب
الاوكراني ولكن هذه المره هناك بيان رسمي
او اعلان رسمي من المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه انه لا علاقه لاوكرانيا او
للجيش الاوكراني بالهجوم الذي حصل في
الكرملين هذا هو تحديد او البيان الرسمي
الوحيد من السلطات الاوكرانيه او اي من
الجهه الرسميه اوكرانيه حول ما حصل ولكن
هناك تشكيك كبير من الراي العام الاوكراني
وكنت اتابع يعني قبل دقائق وسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه بيانات او ما يتحدث بها
السياسيين الاوكرانيين الجميع يشكك في هذه
العمليه ويعتبرها مسرحيه من مسرحيات
الاستخبارات الروسيه
وذلك تحضيرا لهجوم وبدانا نسمع التسويق
للهجوم عبر المحللين الروسي الذين
وتصريحات من جهه ولكن ماذا ما الذي يحدث
على الارض كنا قد استمعنا انه هناك صفارات
الانذار
في اكياس
خبرنا كيف الوضع يعني اكثر من احد عشر
مقاطعه اوكرانيه تدوت فيها سفارات الانذار
وهناك ضربات بالصواريخ والمدفعيه لمدينه
خرسون وسط مدينه خرسون واطرافها ومحطه
القطارات تعرضت لضربات صاروخيه مدينه ايضا
او مقاطعه وفي محيط مدينه ايضا كان هناك
اصوات انفجارات بعد استهدافها بصواريخ اس
ايضا تسمع اصوات انفجارات ناجمه عن
استهداف بالمد
افع القوات الروسيه من المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها في مقاطعه تقوم بقصف بعض الكره او
مراكز تواجد الجيش الاوكراني من ناحيه
اخرى هناك استنفار عام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه
والدفاعات الجويه وهناك يعني يتم الحديث
انه ربما سيكون هناك ضربات صاروخيه مرتقبه
هذه الليله او في الساعات القليله المقبله
للعاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف وعدت من المدن
الاوكرانيه وخاصه ان هناك الان تنبيهات
حول يعني محطات القطارات بعد استخدام بعد
استهداف محطه القطارات في مدينه خرسانه
طيب محمد ذكرت انه على وسائل الاعلام
الكلي يشكك بان تكون اوكرانيا وراء هذه
العمليه اعتبروا ما يحدث مسرحيه بلينكن
ايضا قال ينظر بعين الربا لما حدث
بالكرملين ولكن السؤال لماذا ليس هناك اي
جهه ربما تتوقع ان تكون اوكرانيا وراء هذه
العمليه لانه اوكرانيا غير قادره على
تنفيذ مثل هذه العمليه يشككون بقدرات
قياداتهم للوصول الى العاصمه موسكو او لا
في حكمتهم لانه رد الفعل معروفه والخاسر
بالنهايه سيكون اوكرانيا
يعني لقراءه هذا الحدث يعني ان كانت
اوكرانيا تحضر الاستهداف او الاغتيال
الرئيس فلاديمير
عفوا لن يكون هناك استهداف بمسيره صغيره
الحجم وصغيره التاثير خاصه الجميع يعلم
الاجراءات الامنيه المشدده التي يعني تخضع
فيها موسكو ومنطقه الكريمينا وايضا هناك
تشكيك انه يعني هذه المسيره تم اطلاقها في
وقت كما اعلنت السلطات الروسيه
لم يكن داخل الكرملين ما يؤكد النظريه
الاوكرانيه ان هذه المسرحيه ومسرحيه تسبق
عمل اجرامي او عمل رد فعل او هجوم قد تقوم
به روسيا للاراضي الاوكرانيه وهي كانت
تنتظر الزريعه والان الزريعه هي اتهام
اوكرانيا
باستهداف الكلام ومحاوله وتضخيم هذا
الاستهداف باتهام اوكرانيا بمحاوله اغتيال
فلاديمير بوتين هناك راي عام اوكراني هناك
يعني اشخاص فرحون في اوكرانيا يتكلم به
واقعيه فرحون من هذا الاستهداف ويعتبرون
ان يجب على بوتين ان يدفع ثمن الشهداء
الذين قتلوا منذ بدايه الغزو الاوكراني
لغز الروسي للاراضي الاوكرانيه وان على
بوتين ان يدفع الثمن خاصه ان هناك اعداد
كبيره عشرات الالاف من القتلى في بسبب هذا
الغزو للاراضي الاوكرانيه الذي يعتبره
الجانب الاوكراني وهذا الراي العام
الاوكراني انها هذه العمليه جاءت ضمن
الاطماع البوتينيه لتحقيق روسيا العظمى
وانها اصطدمت في الدفاعات الاوكرانيه
وبقوه وعزيمه الشعب الاوكراني طيب اسمح لي
ان اعود لضيفه الينا الحديث معها الينا
استمعت الى
القراءه الاوكرانيه الى مصحه تعبير ان كان
من
المراقبين او حتى من عامه الشعب فيما
يتعلق بما وصفوه بانها مسرحيه يعني
بالنهايه اذا كانت الضربات ستكون
موجهه بشكل قاسي الى اوكرانيا واذا كان
هناك استهداف للقيادات الكبرى اذا مصحه
تعبير او انهاء كل الخطوط الحمر من خلال
الاستهدافات الروسيه ما الذي يمكن ان
تستفيد منه من خلال اوكرانيا من خلال هذا
الاستهداف اذا كانت هي وراء هذا الاستهداف
والله هذا كان سؤال طرحته امريكا عده مرات
عبر تسريبات مثلا في جريده نيويورك
واثقاله ماذا تستفيد اوكرانيا مثلا من
اغتيالات
للنشطاء الروس مثل بنت الفيلسوف
فماذا استفادت اوكرانيا من اغتيال
هذه البنت وماذا استفادت اوكرانيا من
اغتيال مدون روسي شهير فامريكان حذروا
اوكران لا تلعبوا بالنار
للاسف مثل ما قال ضيفكم من اوكرانيا هناك
البعض يفرح في اوكرانيا وهم
مخطئين لانه كانهم يتناسون مع مين عم
يتعاملوا هم يتعاملون مع الروسي ولكن
سمحوا لانفسهم ان يتعاملوا معه بسخريه
وقالوا اكثر من مره انه يريدون ان يخترقوا
الجبهه والى اخره جورج في جنوب روسيا هي
فهمت بسرعه مع مينا تتعامل اما رئيس
اوكرانيا لم يفهم للاسف وهو يتحمل
المسؤوليه على ما يحدث عليه كان ان يهدا
ان يتفاوت اكثر من مره روسيا تدمرت له هذه
الفرصه لم يستغلها
سيده الينا يعني كان في شروط موضوعه لسحب
القوات قبل بدء التفاوض هذا من قبل
اوكرانيا للتعليق على كلامك تحملين
المسؤوليه الكامله لاوكرانيا والرئيس
الاوكراني باعتبار انك ترين بانهم تحركوا
دون التنسيق مع الحلفاء وتحديدا الولايات
المتحده
امريكان دائما
يحاولون ان يحرض الجيران روسيا وهم حاولوا
مع جورجيا اكثر من مره وحتى في السابق قد
نجحوا ولكن شيء جيدا القياده الجرجير مثلا
في الجنوبيه فهم انه هي خطيره جدا اما حتى
قبل هذه المواجهه القياده الاوكرانيه
الحاليه هي سمحت
باقترابها من منظمه حلف ناتو اكثر من
اللازم وحتى وزير امريكا السابق كيسننجر
هو حذرهم قال من غير معقول انتم جيران
روسيا من غير معقوله تتصرف بهذه الطريقه
فامريكان نعم هم يلعبون مع بلدان مختلفه
مع قيادات مختلفه ان يلعبوا ويتواصلوا مع
السيد الينا انا بس بدي افهم انت تعتقدي
بانه هذه العمليه تمت بطريقه
اوكرانيه خالصه واذا كان الوضع كذلك هل
سترضى الولايات المتحده ان ان يقوم
الاوكران بمثل هذه العمليه والاستفزاز
الكبير دون علمها او يمكن ان يكون هناك رد
فعل
انا اعتمد على ما قاله امريكان نفسه وهم
اكثر من مره سربوا هذه المعلومات الى
وسائل الاعلام المهمه مثل واشنطن بوست هو
محطات تلفزيونيه امريكيه هم قالوا انه كل
العمليات الارهابيه التي قامت بها
اوكرانيا في العمق الروسي هي قد حدثت بدون
تنسيق مع امريكا
وبدون الضوء الاخضر من قبل امريكا
بالعكس رغم التحذيرات الامريكيه في هذا
الشان
نعم الان القياده الروسيه هي لا تتهم
امريكان لا تتهم دول الغرب
وروسيا تقول بان علينا ان
نتخلص من هذا النظام في اوكرانيا لكي تهدا
الامور ولكي يهدى الجميع ولكي
قامت بهذا الشيء هو امر تحصيل حاصل ما يهم
الان ماذا سيحدث في القريب وقد يكون في
القريب العاجل اما عبر توقعات كيف او اما
عبر قراءه موسكو على ما يبدو ان الوضع
متجه الى تصعيد كبير قد يحدث خلال الساعات
القادمه كما نسمع وكما نرى وكما نشاهد
طبعا العديد من مواطني العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ومدن اخرى قد نزلوا يعني او جلسوا الان في
الملاجئ ايضا طبعا تصعيد من قبل موسكو
مطالبات
بضربات اكثر حد يعني جميع استخدام اسلحه
جديده ويمكن اذا كان في معلومات نتحدث
عنها ولكن في ايضا سيناريو طرح من قبل
اوكران انه ربما هناك معارضه داخليه روسيه
تكون وراء مثل هذا الهجوم هل بالفعل في
معارضه قويه روسيه في الداخل وفي قلب
العاصمه موسكو طبيعه
المعارضه ان وجدت هنا كما نلاحظ طبعا عبر
شاشتنا من اللقطات التي يعني تاتي من
موسكو من قبل الزملاء الان الوضع الامني
في الساحه الحمراء هو مغلق بشكل كلي من
الصعب يعني حسب رؤيتنا للموقف ويعني عملنا
كصحفيين في موسكو
الاختراق بشكل بسيط
للاطواق الامنيه التي تفرضها موسكو على
العاصمه الروسيه طبعا وصول مثل يعني هذه
الطائره المسيره يحتاج لاستخبارات يعني
تعمل على مستوى عالي ليس من السهوله اطلاق
طائره مسيره خاصه ان موسكو راحه اليوم
قادره على الرصد قادره على الرصد وراحه
اليوم بالاعلان عن منع كلي لطيران كافه
الدرونات والطائرات من دون طيار فوق
العاصمه موسكو وضواحيها لذلك الموضوع كبير
ورد موسكو قد لا يقتصر على ضربات محدده
طبعا كان الجميع يتحدث عن ضروره العبث
والوصول للخطوط الحمراء اول الخطوط
الحمراء كانت ضرب
الواصل مع شبه جزيره القرم والجميع يعرف
الخطوات التي تبعتها موسكو بعد هذه الضربه
الضرب بشكل كامل لكافه مباني البنيه
الاوكرانيه من خلال العمليه العسكريه لم
يخرج عن هذا الاطار ان كان فيما يتعلق
بالاسلحه وبالتكتيكات اليس كذلك صحيح
ميسون لكن العمليه العسكريه اتجهت نحو
السيطره على مدن الجنوب الاوكراني اما
الضربات كرد فعل على اللعب بالخطوط
الحمراء يعني طالت جميع المدن الاوكرانيه
طالت المباني سياسه الارض المحروقه نتحدث
يمكن ان تكون او محاوله جديده للسيطره على
حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتحدث موسكو عن سياسه
الارض المحروقه لان تفجير الوضع عبر يعني
السيطره على المدن وعدم الاكتراث للوضع
الامني الوضع السكاني وضع الناس وضع
الغذاء سيحرك الوضع في الدخل الروسي
باعتبار ان الشعب الروسي حتى هذه اللحظه
ينظر للشعب الاوكراني على انه شعب شقيق هم
شعب واحد في الاول والاخير لا يمكن لقوات
موسكو ان تتبع سياسه الارض المحروقه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولذلك نلاحظ ان موسكو
لا تتجه نحو ضرب على سبيل المثال الطرقات
وخطوط القطارات التي تقوم بنقل الغذاء الى
مدن الشرق والى مدن الجنوب وهي خطوه طبعا
يمكن ان تكلف موسكو الكثير تفجير الوضع من
الداخل عبر يعني الوضع الانساني في
اوكرانيا قد يكلف موسكو كثيرا لذلك هي
ضربات قد تكون من جهات بعيده من البحر
الاسود من مناطق اخرى من بحر قزوين على
نقاط محدده في الداخل الاوكراني ربما
الحديث عن كيف يطول بهذا الاطار ومعنى من
هناك مدير تحرير موقع اوكرانيا اليوم محمد
العروقي اهلا بك استاذ محمد هل لك ان
تعطينا فكره من خلال رصدك لما يتم تداوله
صحفيا عن ردود الفعل والى اين تتجه الامور
ان كانت هناك من قراءات
يعني تحيه لكم كما جاء في الانباء نستطيع
ان نرفض الرد الفعل الاوكراني الرسمي وهو
النفي التامه على لسان ناطق باسم الرئيس
الاوكراني فبذلك يعني جميع التوقعات هنا
في اوكرانيا انها مسرحيه من تدبير الكريم
لماذا هذه المسرحيه لانه اوكرانيا يعني
على وشك هجوم مضاد لاستعاده الاراضي التي
احتلتها اوكرانيا روسيا عفوا عند بدايه
هذه الحرب فبالتالي الان روسيا اصبحت منذ
شهر او اكثر في مواقع دفاعيه اكثر منها
هجوميه وفي الفتره الاخيره لم تحقق اي شيء
بالتالي روسيا تفكر كيف تدبر الامر وكيف
تستغل الامر لافشال هذا الهجوم لافتح
الفرصه لضرب منشات اخرى غير منشات الطاقه
التي دابت على قصفها خلال فصل الشتاء
استاذ محمد يعني في ظل هذه الروايه الى اي
حد تعتقد انه روسيا عن جد فعلا معنيه باي
اعذار حتى تقوم باي استهدافات جديده
يعني
روسيا الان في في موقف دفاعي روسيا الان
تريد ان تستغل هذا الوضع لتكسل الهجوم
الاوكراني
في عمقها في عاصمتها قبل ايام قليله من
الاحتفالات بالنصر تؤثر على صوره الرئيس
الروسي نفسه
يعني عندما نتحدث عن عن موسكو عن الساحه
الحمراء على الكرملين عن كيف يمكن لطائره
القصيره ان تخترق كل هذه الاجواء وتصل الى
هذه المنطقه هذا من جانب اخر احتفالات عيد
النصر ليست مختصره فقط على روسيا بل على
جميع دول الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
والحلفاء واوكرانيا كانت شريك كبير في هذا
النصر وايضا هذا العيد وهذا اليوم له
خاصيه
عند الشعب الاوكراني فبالتالي اعتقد يعني
ان روسيا تبحث عن مبررات لمزيد من القصف
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه رغم ذلك فان القصف
اصبح لا يحقق شيئا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
اوكرانيا تمتلك مضادات جويه قويه لدرجه
اننا اصبحنا في المده الاخيره نسمع بان
قصف الماء حدث في مكان ما دون نشعر به عكس
بدايه الحرب فبالتالي اعتقد ان روسيا يعني
كما نتوقع ان كثيرون ان هذا الامر كان من
تدبير روسي ولماذا لا تكون الروايه التي
تشير الى ان هناك طرف ثالث ربما معني
بتصعيد
الموقف وتوسيع رقعه الاشتباكات هو من قام
بهذه العمليه يعني هذه
احدى سماح بلجنه تحقيق دوليه بهذا الموضوع
بتقصي الحقائق ومعرفه من يقف وراء هذا
الامر لان الموقف الرسمي الاوكراني كما
ذكرت نفى جمله وتفصيلا وقوفها لاننا نعلم
جميعا كما قلت ان اوكرانيا تستعد لما هو
اكبر من هذه العمليه اوكرانيا لا تتبع او
او تختار اشخاص او او رؤساء اوكرانيا تريد
تحرير اراضيها فبالتالي تستعد لهجوم مضاد
ودعينا نسترجع بالتاريخ يعني المشاهير
والرؤساء وبعض القاده لا يتم يعني امام
العالم كله اختيارهم بهذه الطريقه هناك
امور هناك مندبر لهم السم وغيره بعمليات
الاغتيال المخفيه فبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
القياده الاوكرانيه او العقليه الاوكرانيه
قد تلجا لهذه لهذا الموضوع لتؤجج موقفها
او او لتضعف موقفها اكثر
تحرير موقع اوكرانيا اليوم محمد العروقي
شكرا جزيلا لك واعود الى كاتيا معنا من
موسكو والمزيد من التفاصيل الكافيه اي
ردود فعل جديده
مرحبا ميسون حقيقه الان هناك مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وطبعا وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه تتحدث عن كيفيه وصول هذا
الجسم او الطائرات المسيره الى كان هناك
حديث للخبير العسكري هو ضابط في سابق في
مقر قياده قوات الجويه في الروسيه كان قد
تحدث ان هذا هذه المسيرات وصلت من الشمال
من منطقه الشمال هي قادره على التحليق
لمده لمسافه 10 لعشرين كيلو متر لذلك هناك
توقع بان يكون اطلاق هذه المسيرات من داخل
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وليس من خارجها
بالتالي طبعا هذا ما دعى اليوم لعمده
موسكو الى منع تحليق المسيرات فور فوق
الاجواء العاصمه الروسيه موسكو كما ايضا
اريد ان اشير الى ان هناك مسيره اخرى كانت
قد سقطت في ضواحي في ضواحي روسيا طبعا لم
تؤدي الى سقوط ضحايا ولكنها سقطت بالقرب
من محطه وقود في الضاحيه الروسيه في ضواحل
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو ايضا تحدثت عنها
وسائل الاعلام اذا هو كان هجوم مكثف لهذه
المسيرات على العاصمه الروسيه موسكو كما
تتحدث موسكو ووجهت اصابع اتهام الى الجانب
الاوكراني هذا الجانب ولكن من جانب الاخر
اريد ان اشير الى تصريحات قائد فاجنر قوات
فاجنر الخاصه
الذي تحدث منذ قليل قال ان الهجوم المضاد
الذي توعدت به اوكرانيا لروسيا قد بدا
بالفعل كما يقول هو هو قال انها هذا ما
خرج به قبل قليل
الطيران فقط اريد التاكيد كاتيا على
التصريحات التي ذكرتها فيما يتعلق
بالصحائرات المسيره جاءت من الشمال قادمه
على مسافه 10 ل 20 كلم هاي تصريحات رسميه
ام من متابعين
هي فقط من قبل المتابعين وخبراء بالتحديد
خبراء عسكريين يعملون كانوا يعملون في مقر
قياده قوات الجويه في منطقه الدفاع الجوفي
في موسكو كان قد تحدث الخبير العسكري في
وادي سلاف شوريجن تحدث عن انه قد يكون هذا
هذه المسيره قد وصلت من داخل العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو من مسافه 10 الى 20 كيلومتر
قد وصلت الى الكرملين من الشمال
وسقطت طبعا تم اسقاطها من قبل النظام
الدفاع الجوي في داخل العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو طبعا واسقاطها شكرا كاتيا عربيه من
موسكو واعود الى الينا للحديث عن هذه
النقطه تحديدا اذا مصحت بحسب خبراء
عسكريين وبحسب المراقبين العسكريين بانها
قدمت من الشمال وسارت على مسافه 10
كيلومتر او 20 كيلومتر بمعنى الضربه كانت
من الداخل اكثر ما يحرج
روسيا بحال كانت اوكرانيا وراء هذه
العمليه ان يكون الاستهداف قد جاء من
اوكرانيا الى العاصمه او العكس من قلب
العاصمه
هذا لا يحرج روسيا ابدا لانه للاسف هناك
اختراقات للاسف اكثر من مره مجموعات
اوكرانيه قد وصلت الى
موسكو
وضواحي موسكو كيف اختلت بنت
امراه اوكرانيه ومساعديه وهم كانوا في
ضواحي موسكو فماذا يمنع نفس المجموعات
اوكرانيه ان
تقوم باطلاق وبارسال طائره مسيره من عمق
الاراضي الروسيه هذا ممكن ان يحدث للاسف
بسهوله خاصه انهم
قريبين
بمظهرهم شقر وفي كثير من الاحوال
الناس ممكن لن يهتموا بهم ويفتكروهم رو
لبعض الوقت وبدايه
العمليات العسكريه كان هناك من المراقبين
من تخوف ان تتحول الحرب الى حرب عالميه
ثالثه ومن ثم بعد ان بدات الامور تبقى
بشكل نسبي يعني محدوده داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه استبعدنا هذه النظريه ايضا
كانت تصريحات من روسيا تتحدث لا نووي الا
اذا احتجنا لا تختبرون ولكن كان هناك
استبعاد في قضيه استخدام النووي هل
اقتربنا الان اكثر فاكثر الى الحديث عن
هذه النظريه مجددا نظريه الحرب العالميه
الثالثه او استخدام النووي
والوضع خطر بلا شك بس
في حاله نجاح القوات الروسيه الان ممكن
بالعكس نبتعد عن هذا السيناريو لانه اكثر
من مره افوت نقاء لانه يريد انهاء هذه
المواجهه باسرع وقت ممكن فاكيد انه لكي
تنتهي هذه المواجهه ممكن ان تكون هناك
حالتين هي حاله اجراء المفاوضات بشكل ناجح
هي حاله التغلب العسكري او الفوز العسكري
من قبل احد الاطراف
روسيا الان تراهن على فوزها في هذه
المواجهه وبهذا الشكل هي ممكن ان تنتهي
طيب اسمحي لي ان اعود الى مراسل العربيه
عبد الجواد معي في الاستوديو للحديث عن
القراءه من خلال متابعتك لتصريحات الروسيه
المختلفه خلال كل هذه الفتره استمعنا الى
التصريح الاساسي وهو الاتهام البعض يقول
بانه متسرع خاصه انه ليس هناك من دلائل او
تفاصيل حول ما حدث بطبيعه الحال الولايات
المتحده طبعا ردودها معروفه تنظر بنظره شك
حول هذه التصريحات الروسيه ماذا نتوقع ان
يكون وكيف يمكن ان يكون الخطاب الروسي في
هذه المرحله تحديدا ومن بيده القرار
اللفظي للاعلان عن اي رد ممكن ان يكون
قاسي متطرف كما تقول اوكرانيا
ساجيبك بما سالتي لكن في البدايه اسمعي لي
ان اقف عند النقطه التي تحدثت عنها
الزميلي كاتيا يعني عندما يتحدث العسكريين
الروس حول
خطه ما او ان هذه الطائرات المسيره مرت
عبر عشره او عشرين كيلو متر من شمال موسكو
هم يعرفون جيدا ماذا يقولون يعني التسريب
مقصود من قبل لماذا لا تخرج لماذا لا تخرج
القيادات الروسيه
يعرف جيدا ماذا يقول لذلك هو اختراق ابني
قد تكون كيف لها دور كبير فيه او
استخبارات غربيه تلعب دور محوري بهذا
الموضوع لكن الرد اليوم هو صاحب القرار
بهذا الموضوع جميع العقول الروسيه المعنيه
بالداخل الروسي
تذهب للابتعاد عن اعلان وضع الحرب في
البلاد والبقاء على العمليه العسكريه
النواب وتصريحاتهم يجب ان نعتمد عليها بس
تصريحات خطيره مقال اقامه لا خطوط حمراء
الى اخره الى اي حد يمكن ان نقرا اذا كان
العسكري السابق قادر على اعطاء معلومه
رسميه صحيحه ماذا عن النواب هل يمكن ان
نعتمد على تصريحاتهم على اساس انها ربما
اشارات جديه لما يمكن ان يحدث او لا هي
اشارات جديه بشكل واقعي باعتبار ان اي
قرار بروسيا يجب ان يمر عبر مجلس الدمى
ومن ثم رفعه الى مجلس الاتحاد ومن ثم الى
الرئيس الروسي لكن طبعا القراءه في البلاد
لا تتجه نحو اعلان الحرب بشكل كبير بشكل
رسمي لان اعلان وضع الحرب في البلاد يحول
البلاد واقتصاد البلاد الى وضع الحرب وهذا
شيء قد ينهك روسيا وتدخل في مطبات يعني
الازمه الاقتصاديه بشكل كبير لكن الوضع
اليوم داخل العمليه العسكريه مع توسيع
الضربات مع التصعيد بشكل كبير لكن ما
يتحدث عنه الدمى ليس للمراه يعني ليست هي
المره الاولى التي يطالبون فيها القياده
الروسيه بتصعيد الموقف نحو العمليه دعني
اعود الى الينا حول هذه النقطه تحديدا
فيما يتعلق بالرد الفعل الروسي هل روسيا
تفكر في رد الفعل الاوكراني بالمقابل بحال
بالفعل استخدمت هذه الاسلحه الجديده بحال
بالفعل وصلت ان كان الى مقر الرئاسه او
غيرها من المناطق التي او المقر التي كانت
تعتبر خط احمر الينا
ولكنني متاكده انه روسيا عملت حساباتها
وروسيا تراهن على نجاحها فالتصريحات حول
انه اوكران قد كانهم بداوا بالهجوم هي
تعني بانه روسيا من ناحيتها كمان ممكن ان
تقوم
بنفس العمليات الهجوميه ببعض المناطق
وعلى اقل هي حتى استمر في صد
الهجوم الاوكراني ولكنني اعتقد انه سيكون
شيء اكثر والقوات الروسيه ستحاول ان تتقدم
على الجبهات وبالنسبه لكلام وتصريحات رئيس
البرلمان الروسي سيد وبعض النواب نعم هي
خطيره هي تدعو للقضاء على النظام في
اوكرانيا
ولكنني اعتقد انه هي ليست تصري قطعه قويه
وراءها
طيب وصلت الرساله
من موسكو الينا المستشاره السياسيه في
مركز الدراسات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
وشكرا طبعا لعبد الجواد الرشد مراسل
العربيه متواجد معنا طبعا في الاستوديو
ونبقى مشاهدينا باخر الاخبار على الاقل
تطورات الميدانيه التي تشهدها الحرب
الدائره على الاراضي الاوكرانيه مراسل
العربيه اكد بان قوات باجنر الروسيه تقدمت
في عمق المحور الغربي من مدينه بافموت
وايضا سيطرت على مساحات اضافيه مراسل
العربيه ايضا اضاف الى ان المعارك اشتدت
حول الطريق السريع في بلده رومادا شمال
الغربيه المدينه وكريسنايا في نفس المحور
كما وسع الجيش الروسي من تطويقه لمدينه
الدليفكا بعد عمليه عسكريه عنيفه اشار
ايضا المراسل الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه
شنت هجوما مضاده على الجيش الروسي في
مناطق القتال وذلك غربي مدينه مارينكا
ايضا بالمقابل السلطات المحليه الاوكرانيه
اعلنت فرض حظر تجوال في خرسون طبعا هي
واقعه قربه خط الموجهه وذلك اعتبارا من
مسائل الجمعه ولمده 58 ساعه رئيس الاداره
العسكريه المحليه الكسندر بروكوديين قد
افاد على التيليجرام انه خلال حظر التجوال
سيمنع التنقل في شوارع المدينه
ايضا اعلن جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي
احباط انشطه شبكه تابعه للمخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه كانت تخطط لتنفيذ
هجمات ارهابيه في شبه جزيره القرم كما اكد
الجهاز في بيان ان المتفجرات التي تمت
مصادرتها من المعتقلين اثناء التحضير
لهجمات ارهابيه في القرن تتطابق مع تلك
المستخدمه في تفجير خطوط السكك الحديديه
في الثالث والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
انتهت التغطيه لهذه الساعه ولكن التغطيه
مستمره على الراس الساعه معرشه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات